petit à petit on voit bien que les
symboles de l'état sont de plus en plus
contestée non seulement bien sûr les
policiers les gendarmes
on voit en plus en plus de difficulté
sont attaqués mais également les
pompiers mais également les maires etc
donc on a une perte globale neutralité
de l'état on a un recul de la république
et ce sont des phénomènes qui sont très
inquiétants quand on vit dans une
république
quand les républicains ce que je suis
con et démocrates ce que je suis bien
sûr si une également
mais on voit bien que lien il ya un
sujet alors moi je pense que parce
qu'une fois qu'on a posé ce diagnostic
faut essayer de trouver une solution
je pense que la première de la première
difficulté c'est jallet dit à l'absence
de sanction c'est pas vrai naturellement
mais les difficultés de sanctionner et
le fait que de plus en plus de personnes
pensent qu'ils sont intouchables ou
qu'ils échappent à la sanction
c'est la première chose qu'il faut faire
je pense c'est la certitude de la
sanction
quand vous faites quand vous faites une
infraction quelle qu'elle soit ça peut
être un feu rouge ça peut être quelque
chose de très grave
vous devez être sanctionné cette
sanction et doit être juste et doit être
proportionnelle naturellement moi j'ai
jamais fait partie des gens qui
voulaient des des sanctions est
épouvantable et mais quand vous êtes
condamné vous devez la faire une partie
du monde de dijon 2-2 de la gauche
judiciaire qui considère qu' il faut un
numerus clausus dans les prisons voilà
alors on le dit pas exactement comme ça
mais c'est la réalité c'est-à-dire qu'on
attend de places de prison
on doit pas avoir plus de détenus c'est
pour ces cités qui est trois quatre cinq
personnes par service à 100 en termes de
gestion des prisons mais ça ne s'entend
pas du tout en terme de sanction et en
termes d'état de droit sert que si à
passer de passe en prison il faut en
construire là aujourd'hui
l'idée c'est que vous ne pouvez rentrer
en prison que si quelqu'un on sort ce
qui fait que déjà on voit que pour la
sanction au départ quand vous rentrez
sais pas si simple puisque vous êtes
condamné vous n'allez pas y aller mais
vous êtes condamné à deux ans de prison
et vous n'allez pas les faire parce
qu'il ya un moment où à faire sortir
plus tôt on a bien vu d'ailleurs au
moment du duc au vide le misa justice a
à libérer 13000 un peu plus de 13 mille
détenus 20 % des détenus
on nous l'a vendu en deux ans et des
femmes peinent naturellement ce pas vrai
20% des femmes des détenus c'est pas des
gens qui étaient à 15 jours de la sortie
pour ces gens là évidemment ne sont plus
en prison donc la gestion à l'intérieur
de la prison sont trouve facilitée mais
par contre
de nouveau à l'extérieur et je ne suis
pas surtout la totalité d'entre eux
aient décidé de s'acheter une conduite
c'est un mot qui est terrible sentiment
d'insécurité pas ce que ça veut dire aux
gens en fait c'est le fantasme de
sécurité c'est un sentiment mais c'est
pas vrai vous n'avez pas été tech et
vous n'avez pas peur n'aie pas été
violée on n'a pas cassé votre voiture
c'est un sentiment voilà et c'est
insupportable pour les gens qui ont subi
ça et même pour les gens qu'ils n'ont
pas subi le simple fait d'avoir peur
c'est pas un fantasme d'avoir peur quand
vous avez peur même s'il n'arrive rien
c'est que quelque part l'état a failli
voilà c'est pour ça que ce faut jamais
parler à mon sens de sentiment
d'insécurité parce que les gens prennent
mal parce que diaby est d'accord mais si
j'ai peur c'est que je suis un
trouillard
c'est un fantasme voilà donc il n'y a
pas de sentiment d'insécurité ya de
l'insécurité elle est réelle elle
augmente elle doit être maîtrisable
encore faut-il qu'on en prenne
conscience
vous ne pouvez arriver à quelque chose
dans un pays comme le nôtre que si le
président de la république lui-même
simple it je constate que ça fait trois
ans que mais le maquereau un président
de la république et que finalement il
s'est peu exprimé sur ces sujets et qui
là et qu'on a peu avancé dans le domaine
de la sécurité
le en même temps ça peut pas marcher
d'ailleurs vous pouvez pas avoir en même
temps un ministre de l'intérieur qui dit
je vais être ferme et impitoyable et de
l'autre côté un ministre de la justice
qui explique que doit y avoir personne
dans les prisons vous pouvez pas
conduire une voiture avec à la fois le
pied sur l'accélérateur et le pied sur
le frein c'est j'ai l'impression c'est
un petit peu ce qui est en train de se
passer aujourd'hui